Ladies and gentlemen, on behalf of
the Board of Trustees and the members of
the Academy, I now present you with the
tenth president of Carnegie University,
Dr. Farnam Jahanian.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Congratulations.
>> Thank you.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you.
Thank you very much.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>>Thank you very much
>>[APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you very much.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Wow.
Chairman Rohr, trustees,
faculty, colleagues, students,
staff, alumni and honored guests,
good morning, and thank you.
It's a great honor and
a truly humbling experience to stand
here as the tenth president of
Carnegie Mellon University.
I hereby accept the symbols,
the Office of the President and
all of the responsibility
pertaining thereto.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> It brings me great joy to celebrate
this occasion with my family,
especially my wife Tris and
my children, Daniel, Thomas, and Sarah.
Who have always been-
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Who have always been my greatest blessing.
I am so touched by the presence of
friends, former students, colleagues and
collaborators who have traveled
from across the country to be here.
Also, I want to acknowledge
community partners and
civic leaders from the Pittsburgh region
who are showing their support for
this university today and every day
and I would especially like
to thank my dear friends,
Marlene Behrmann, Keith Block
and Martha Pollack for
their kind and
thoughtful words this morning.
Martha, I've been
following your footsteps.
>> [LAUGH]
>> What you didn't tell them is that,
you were my department head, and
my provost, my boss for many, many years.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I don't know what you
are planning to do next.
I'm pretty happy to be here,
so don't do anything else.
>> [LAUGH]
>>APPLAUSE]
>> Today's ceremony is a celebration
steeped in tradition.
The singing of our national anthem,
our academic regalia.
The iconic sound of bagpipes.
These rituals remind us
that at this moment,
it's not about the beginning
of my journey as president.
Rather, this ceremony celebrates
our storied history as a
community of scholars in a nation
driven by learning and discovery.
CMU is relatively a young university.
We've come so far in such a short time
and our accomplishments would have not
been possible without the leadership of
my predecessors.
I especially want to acknowledge and
thank President Emeritus Jerry Cohon and
past Provost-
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> and past provost Mark Kamlet-
>> for their-
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> for their enduring commitment
to this university.
We are so grateful to you for
everything you have done for
Carnegie Mellon, Mark and Jerry.
[APPLAUSE]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Of course,
great leaders are inspired by
an extraordinary community.
As Mark and Jerry can attest,
countless faculty, staff, alumni
and partners helped to build a foundation
of excellence CMU enjoys today.
I am grateful to all the men and
women who have guided
this university since its founding,
and who will secure its future.
In particular, I wish to recognize
the members of Carnegie Mellon's Board of
Trustees who are the stewards
of this institution.
I am so grateful for
their trust they have placed in me.
Trustees, would you please
stand to be recognized?
Carnegie Mellon Trustees.
[APPLAUSE]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you.
Please be seated.
I would also like to acknowledge and thank
the university deans, vice provost and
executive management team,
my co-conspirators who do so
much to advance CMU everyday.
Would the university leadership team,
please stand to be recognized.
[APPLAUSE]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Like many of us here,
I left home as a teenager
to pursue an education.
As I prepared for
my journey from Iran to Texas,
I remember asking my
mother to help me pack.
She said, "pack light because whatever
you need, you will find there."
Pack light because whatever you need,
you will find there.
And so as I left home, with little
more than a sense of optimism, and
a desire to make the most of
the incredible opportunities
that only an education in
the United States could provide.
I've carried my mother's words
with me over these many years.
I think her advice may have been based
on hope that I would return home
once the initial excitement wore off,
but I was pretty stubborn.
In fact, I got my tenacity from her
along with a work ethic
instilled in me by my father.
My siblings who are here
can attest to that.
But looking back, perhaps my mother
was hinting at the knowledge
I would accumulate in the journey ahead.
As a teacher and advisor,
I came to understand the incredible
power of education to change lives.
As a researcher, mentor, entrepreneur,
I observed the potential of
a single idea to launch a new enterprise
or disrupt an entire industry.
And during my time in public
service in Washington DC,
I saw how these ideas,
how the ideas emerging from higher
education serve as the foundation
of our success as a nation.
My 30-year career ultimately led me here,
to this city and
this university, this community.
Our community embodies all of my most
fervent beliefs and my greatest passions.
Every day at CMU, I am inspired by you.
Here, the world's most ambitious
students collaborate at the edges and
intersections of diverse fields, and
go on to change the world as alumni.
Here, faculty leave an indelible mark
on society through their scholarship.
Here, professionals and
dedicated staff create an environment
that support our shared success.
These are the people and the ideals that
set CMU apart from the very beginning,
when Andrew Carnegie founded
the Carnegie Technical Schools to educate
the sons and
daughters of factory workers in 1900.
Early, it's in evolution,
this institution would house two great
learning environments, the College of
Engineering and the College of Fine Arts.
You see, right from the start,
we were bringing together creativity and
industry.
Our willingness to take risks
continued into the 20th century,
when we became the first degree granting
drama institution in the United States
and then when the Mellon Institute
of Research founded by
Richard Andrew Mellon merged with Carnegie Tech,
to create Carnegie Mellon University
and again, when Newell, Simon, Perlis, and
Raj Reddy came to dominate the emerging
field of computer science
and established artificial intelligence
as the next frontier in human progress.
To paraphrase CS pioneer Grace Hopper,
the most
dangerous phrase in the English language
is, "we've always done it this way."
So at a time when computers were
barely understood, we were among
the very first to recognize the power of
computing and we made some big bets.
In 1965, we established our
Department of Computer Science.
In 1979, we founded the first
Robotics Institute at a US university.
In 1984, we attracted funding
from the federal government
to launch
the Software Engineering Institute.
And in 1988,
we announced the first college in the
world devoted solely to computer science.
Ours is still the model
that others follow.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> In the process,
we've created new fields of inquiry,
such as machine learning, transition
design, and the science of learning.
We've magnified our societal impact
through technologies like autonomous
vehicles and additive manufacturing
and we did all of this, while also
cleaning up at the Tonys, the Emmys and
the Putnam competition.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> There's a lot to be gained
by looking back at our past.
We see who we are, who we've always been.
Alumni from those early years
would certainly see themselves
in today's students,
entrepreneurial, creative,
collaborative, whip smart,
and just a little bit quirky.
>> [LAUGH]
>> While the past has left a bright trail,
the future is arriving faster
than anyone could have predicted
and you've heard several
speakers talk about that.
Our entire world is adapting to
unprecedented advances that are rapidly
transforming our economy,
our society, and our culture.
We must ask ourselves, how can higher
education fit into this dazzling future?
Indeed, our industry has
recently come under scrutiny.
This is not a new phenomenon.
Academic institutions have often been seen
as, or criticized rather, as ivory towers.
But there is no doubt that sustained
investment in research and
education has fueled our nation's
broad prosperity since World War II.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Universities exemplify our faith in
the power of education to transcend
social, economic and racial divides.
To reinforce our role as
pillars of progressive society,
higher education must
approach our mission with
renewed attention to the unique
demands of tomorrow.
At stake is the ability of our
society to retain its fundamental
commitment to democracy, truth,
equity and freedom of expression.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> At Carnegie Mellon,
we have always responded to challenges
with trademark fearlessness.
I'm reminded of the leadership
of Dick Cyert, who not only not
pioneered a new model for business
education as dean of our business school,
but would later serve as one of
the most visionary CMU presidents.
More than 40 years ago, he made bold,
but calculated investments in the very
areas that define our leadership today.
These risks were not always met with
broad support, but they paid off.
As a result,
CMU grew from a small regional institution
to an international center
of higher education.
The time to be intentionally
bold is once again upon us.
We have a singular opportunity to
wield our exceptional strength,
and make the next big investments
in our global leadership.
Let's consider together what society
needs most from academic institutions
in the context of our two core missions,
research and education.
At CMU, we advance human knowledge
through scholarly research, and
forge new connections to our
humanity through the arts.
But the nature of research and
creativity is rapidly changing,
increasingly becoming dependent on
people working across the boundaries of
established disciplines, and
on computational data-driven
approaches that are accelerating
discovery and innovation.
This is precisely where CMU excels.
In fact, we have cultivated
a distinct leadership where these
two areas intersect at the nexus
of technology and society.
Through this expertise we're enhancing
the way we live, work and communicate
and we're shaping modern culture through
visionary art, performance and design.
CMU legend, Herb Simon once said, "we're
not observers of the future, we're actors."
Our job is to design a sustainable and
acceptable world and bring it about.
This remains true, as true today as
when he said it more than 20 years ago.
What has also remained constant is
the tremendous responsibility that
comes with this influence.
I was reminded of this last year when I
came across an editorial by David Brooks
in the New York Times which reflected
on Pittsburgh's renaissance.
Of course, our connection to this
city is one of our greatest strengths.
But this article,
while acknowledging CMU's positive impact,
also warned of a so-called
Carnegie Mellon layer of prosperity
that had not quite penetrated
working class neighborhoods.
Indeed, we are witnessing
the disfranchisement of a growing
segment of our population.
People who just do not see themselves
as part of this new economy,
who can't even imagine a pathway to entry.
While the nature of this divide has
been debated
by pundits on the left and on right,
this goes far beyond partisan politics.
We all bear responsibility for
ensuring that the future we're
building works for everyone.
If we succeed,
the United States will continue to serve
as a shining example of prosperity and
democracy for the rest of the world.
Here lies the greatest obligation for
institutions of higher
learning in the modern era and
a commitment that lies at
the heart of CMU's leadership.
Even as we break new ground in technology,
we must work to mitigate any
consequences that diminish
human dignity and opportunity.
That is why at CMU, scientists and
engineers work together with philosophers,
artists, economists who will
shape what might be possible.
With ethicists, humanists,
and policy experts,
who will guide our path and
with the behavioral scientists
who will measure the impact
of our work on humanity.
Reinforcing our distinct strength at
the nexus of technology and humanity will
be crucial to building an extraordinary
momentum in both research and creativity.
And as president, I am committed
to supporting this leadership
by investing in a diverse community
of faculty and researchers,
by doubling down on our partnership
beyond the borders of our campus and
by creating vibrant, living laboratories
in communities around the world.
This is the next frontier for
Carnegie Mellon and
I believe it will only deepen our
societal impact heading into the future.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> As much as we value our impact of or
our research and
creativity, we are equally committed
to our educational mission.
And as a CMU parent,
the responsibility of preparing the next
generation is deeply personal to me.
To the CMU students here today and
also across various campuses,
and our campus watch parties,
You are my most important motivation.
You're spending your most
formative years here.
From what I remember from
my own college experience,
you are undoubtedly forming
lifelong friendships.
You know, many of my best friends from college
are still my best friends today.
The foundation you built here will
sustain you as you enter a world defined
by continuous disruption.
According to a recent study, about
two thirds of jobs that you will hold
throughout your lives, do not even exist.
This reality has dramatic and
immediate implications for
the kind of education you deserve today.
Throughout our history, every period
of significant technological change
has been met with a corresponding
wave of innovation in education.
I'm here to tell you that, right now,
we are at the dawn of the next
major transformation in education
and Carnegie Mellon will be at
the forefront of these changes,
from curriculum to pedagogy to
structure and organization.
We are re-imagining our education
with your futures in mind.
We're breaking down disciplinary silos and
launching
cross-cutting programs that better serve
your interests and society's needs.
Programs like behavioral economics,
neuroscience and IDEATE.
We're embedding continuous
learning in the skills that will
only increase in demand as automation
re-shapes the future of work,
Skills like communication,
critical thinking, and entrepreneurship.
We're investing in infrastructure that
supports the new ways that students learn
and collaborate,
spaces like Tepper Quad and Scott Hall.
We're utilizing our expertise in
the science of learning to develop
a personalized model of education
focused on how each of you learns best.
Every day we work to build and
sustain a community that's inclusive,
equitable, nurturing for
both graduate and undergraduate students,
a place where diverse
perspectives can come together
in a culture of civil
discourse.  To our students,
thank you for entrusting us with this
most important chapter in your lives.
You will always be at
the heart of my presidency.
As we consider -
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> As we consider the aspirations that
unite this global community,
philanthropy must continue to catalyze and
support our forward momentum.
In fact, this university was
founded by an act of philanthropy.
At this pivotal moment,
I am delighted today to announce
two extraordinary new commitments
that will provide critical
resources to Carnegie Mellon.
In recent years, Carnegie Mellon has
been making significant investments for
our College of Engineering,
including a state of the art maker
ecosystem that serves the entire campus.
Today I'm pleased to announce
that The Allegheny Foundation
has committed a $30
million lead grant toward
the transformation of Scaife Hall
into a modern new home for
our Mechanical Engineering Department.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> This grant, the largest in the history
of Allegheny Foundation,
will enable us to bring our total
infrastructure investments in engineering
over the last decade to more
than a quarter billion dollars.
With this commitment, CMU will be better
able to compete for best students and
faculty, driving Pittsburgh's
reputation as a hub for innovation.
We're joined today by Matt Groll,
President and Chairman of
Allegheny Foundation, please join me
in thanking Allegheny Foundation for
their generosity to Carnegie Mellon.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Matt, please stand to be recognized.
>> At a time when college education has
never been more important,
many prospective students and
middle class families feel as
though they're simply priced
out of education that they may need for
the future.
This is why CMU has made growing our
endowment for scholarships, fellowships and
financial aid one of our most
important strategic priorities.
Today I am pleased to
announce that CMU Trustee,
Tod Johnson and
his wife Cindy have committed
$50 million to create
an endowment to support
undergraduate scholarship and
student success.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> You know, I made the announcement a couple of times
yesterday and I said this last night,
every time I'm making this announcement,
when I get to the word student,
I choke up.
That's why we're here.
Tod and Cindy will you stand please,
to be recognized.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Well, I lost my place.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Boy, I didn't realize this speech was this long.
>> I know, tell me about it.
>> Well.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Back to the place that
I lost track of time.
>> [LAUGH]
>> This support will
greatly expand our ability to
ensure that a Carnegie Mellon
education Is within the reach
of all talented students.
This gift,the largest toward scholarship
support in Carnegie Mellon's history,
was inspired by Tod's own path
to success here at CMU and
the fellowship that funded his education.
Please once again, join me in thanking and
congratulating the Johnson's for their
generosity and commitment to our students.
Todd and Cindy we are so
grateful to you for your generosity.
[APPLAUSE]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I hope you packed a good lunch,
this is a long speech.
>> [LAUGH]
>> My fellow Tartans,
whether you're in Pittsburgh,
Silicon Valley,
Australia, Rwanda or Qatar,
I hope you are as excited
as I am about the future of
Carnegie Mellon University.
To be part of CMU at
this moment is to be at
the cusp of the next great phase
of societal and human development.
If we continue doing what we do today,
we'll maintain momentum and
continue to be a great university,
but if we are very intentional,
if we are unapologetically bold,
and if we are committed to taking risks,
I am confident
that we will position ourselves among
the top tier institutions in the world.
A place that's known for
the writing the story of this century,
an institution dedicated
to anticipating and
solving the most pressing
challenges facing humanity.
Through creative inquiry,
through scientific discovery,
through the impact of technology, and
through a transformative
education that changes lives.
As we embark on this exhilarating
future together, we do so
as a community bound together
by a set of core values
that serve as our foundation, integrity,
knowledge, compassion, respect.
The great scientist,
Albert Einstein understood
this fundamental connection between
excellence and human values.
In 1950 he wrote, "Only morality in our
actions can give beauty and
dignity to life.
To make this a living force and
bring it to clear consciousness,
is perhaps the foremost task of education."
Andrew Carnegie put it a little bit
more simply, "My heart is in the work."
Each one of us has a role to
play in bringing beauty and
dignity to our mission through
the impact we make on society,
the leaders we develop, and
opportunities we create for others.
I feel privileged to work with
such outstanding partners, and
I look forward to all that
we will achieve together.
Thank you very much. >> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you
>> [APPLAUSE]